[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in tim mcmahon espn nba
reporter and uh he joins us on the
program i guess the knicks are back tim
you just hire you know a player's dad
and you could finally get somebody to
sign with the knicks uh so is this great
news for jalen brunson
i mean it's absolutely great yeah great
i think it's great news for jaylen
brunson for sure and i do think you're
over simplifying things a little bit
with rick brunson being hired as
assistant coach it's not like he's a a
nobody it's not like he doesn't have
deep connections to the knicks and this
is the reason part of the reason that
the knicks were always considered at
least somewhat of a threat leon rose
former power agent rick brunson was his
first client he represented jalen
brunson on his rookie deal uh rick
brunson has known tom thibodeau since
tips was coaching at salem state and and
rick brunson was at salem high this is
this will be the third time that he's
been on tibbs staff but look
they're not getting
jaylen brunson just because of all those
ties they're not getting him just
because they're saying hey you come here
the ball's in your hands you are our
primary playmaker you are our starting
point guard you don't have to be in a
shadow they are getting him because they
are going to put more than 100 million
dollars
on the table they are out bidding the
mavericks by a significant margin and
you know especially when you have the
other factors on your side the money
talks
why is dallas letting him go
dallas let him go because
frankly it got to a point or it will get
to a point since negotiations haven't
started yet
uh where the the money's just too much
for the mavs taste i was told they were
more than comfortable going five years
for him he definitely was priority
number one going into uh the off-season
they felt like a fair comp was quote
more than fred van bleet money so you're
talking 22 maybe 23 a year
you know five years 110 115 you're not
getting close i mean the knicks might
get get at or near that point on a
four-year deal so
and and i do think that part of this is
jalen brunson you know probably getting
a taste of this during the playoffs
those three games lucas sat he goes for
41 against the jazz he goes for 31
against the jazz hey i i can run a show
and that's just that is something that
the mavericks could not offer they're
not going to take the ball out of lucas
hands to feature him he fit very well
next to luca but you know i you can't
blame a young ascending player for
wanting more for himself both
financially and in terms of role yeah
but the mavs can't afford to have less
talent surrounding luca
you're absolutely right and look there
is no question this is a big blow to the
mavericks they are losing the second
best player from a team that just went
to the western conference finals and
they'll tell you well hey we got spencer
didn't woody we expect him to be even
better this year tim hardaway jr is
coming back but there's there's no spin
there's no way i can sit here and tell
you this is not a significant hit to the
mavericks and in hindsight and frankly
even in foresight they should have
gotten the extension done with brunson
when they had a chance if they to put
four for 56 on the table last summer
he'd sign in a heartbeat rick brunson
told me during the playoffs that they
went to the mavericks in january and
said hey you put it on the table now
we'll sign that deal the mavericks
waited until after the trade wait how
much was the money for tim that was four
years 56 million 55.6 million it's the
exact same contract it was the most they
could give him on an extension it was
the exact same contract dorian finney
smith signed man that is immediately
after the trade that's 50 million
less than what he's going to be making
well and isn't isn't brunson happy that
that happened at this point
the mavs made the calculated decision
not to offer it to
brunson or dory and finney smith until
after the trade deadline because if a
deal popped up for a star they want they
knew they're probably gonna have to
include one or both of those guys that
deal didn't pop up they got dorian
finney smith done they're going to lose
jaylen brunson so you can say that
calculator risk certainly backfired
i mentioned this yesterday i'd been
given a heads up two days ago to keep an
eye on d'andre eight and the possibility
he could end up with the nets so i had
my guys check and see what the odds were
and they were astronomical that he was
going to leave phoenix and certainly end
up with the nets then all of a sudden it
went crazy
the second best odds of landing deandre
ayton behind the phoenix suns
are the nets
how are they going to pull this off if
that were to happen is ben simmons
expendable
i mean i would certainly say that he's
expendable i think the question there is
is is that a risk that the suns are
willing to take uh given the fact this
guy just sat out a year he's coming off
of back surgery i i don't know though
that there's a clear landing spot for
deandre ayton right now people thought
when the pistons created that cap space
that hey that's it you know the pistons
are going to put that max offer sheet on
the table uh that's not happening the
the pistons have done you know they they
got during the center uh via the knicks
in the draft um you know they they just
used 19 million dollars to help the mix
clear that cap space taken neural is
noel taken alec burke's they don't have
max cap space anymore certainly the
net's been mentioned as a potential sign
and trade destination and i've heard
rumblings about the raptors uh you know
i've heard rumblings about the spurs but
you know i i i can't sit here and tell
you that i have a good feel on where
deandre ayton is going
i'm not certain that that he does and
you know maybe the answer is
that the sons resign him and basically
he's back on the you know he's on the
trade market as soon as he's eligible to
be talking the one thing i can't imagine
is the sun's losing him for absolutely
nothing that would be really bad
business we're talking to tim mcmahon he
covers the nba for espn
i think it feels like we moved on from
kyrie irving because he opted back in
and i thought no
like it's still
this is still an issue it feels like tim
like wait he they didn't sign him to the
max he's back for a year maybe
begrudgingly you got durant who's there
for four years
i don't know but my thoughts on your
thoughts on kyrie
that he's back for a year
is this a story that we move on from
right now well i just appreciate kyrie
daring to go in a different direction by
not volunteering to take a 30 million
pay cut i mean what a revolutionary
this guy is
no i've honestly him opting in i think
probably increases the likelihood that
uh you know that he could get traded
because they sign in trade where he's
signing a multi-year contract at max
money oh boy that's a big commitment
from another team now the fact that he
is an expiring contract that you can you
know
if and the talent is obvious nobody ever
has questioned kyrie irving's talent but
the
uh you know the desire to commit to him
given the lack of dependability is is
frightening and
with him being on on a essentially a
one-year deal now that isn't a factor uh
certainly i think the nets have made it
clear that they wanted no part of a
long-term commitment so
i certainly would not be surprising if
he ends up being moved at some point uh
i don't know if it's this summer or
before the deadline but no that story's
not over felt like the lakers were
desperate
are the lakers desperate
i i would say when you have
lebron james who is still playing at the
level that he has and you know knowing
how much he how much pressure he puts on
a franchise to go all in for competing
for championships yes you're desperate
um
you know again you talk about difficult
decisions oh russell russell westbrook
wants to make 47 million dollars this
year do you think anybody else is giving
him that kind of money of course he's
gonna of course he's gonna opt in
um
and that's not
that's not the best route for the lakers
uh you know we'll see if he ends the
season in la they've got to figure out
how to make that work um
i did laugh when darvingham during his
opening press conference says we want we
want russ to get back to playing
championship caliber defense i was i'm
trying to find maybe like his high
school film i don't know when the last
time he played championship caliber
defense was well you're a little snarky
here tim i like it i like it you know
they they they're people who with the
lakers said that russ refused to play
defense last year like he gave no effort
whatsoever and you're bringing in a
hard-nosed guy in darvanham i know he
said all the nice things
but
uh it felt like you got to say nice
things before we ship you out of town i
don't know what you can do
it feels like you're stuck with him at
least this upcoming season yeah or you
have to say nice things because you know
you have to try to make this work
because that 47 million dollar contract
for a guy that you know if russ is a
free agent people would be interested in
him at a you know a mid-level type of
money i think
it's just going to be so difficult to
move him uh unless it's a buyout
situation so you're darving ham you
realize hey it's very likely this guy's
on the roster i really need to try to
make this work so you know the way to do
that is not going in and
you know being disrespectful and calling
him out
he but he he called him out in a very
polite encouraging manner you know by
emphasizing the defense because you say
you know people in la last year said
that russ didn't even try on defense
well guess what you can find people who
said that in washington and in houston
and in oklahoma city i mean there's a
little bit of a trend here
uh
john walter the clippers it feels like
given everything that's happened that
was one of those oh and john wall went
to the clippers
i like it
um if there's not that much risk and
maybe he has pride that he wants to
prove that he can play championship uh
you know style basketball here how does
this work with the clippers
yeah i like it and again similar to russ
nobody wanted to pay him 47 million but
for that tax pay uh the taxpayer
mid-level about six and a half million
dollars i think it's very good value
he didn't play much for the rockets
obviously but in those 40 games he
proved he can still produce
now he's going to come into la and
obviously that's kawhi leonard's team
and then it's paul george what they've
really been missing is a is a play
makers kind of a table setter john wall
throughout his career has been one of
the best passers in the nba and you know
i i think that's the attraction for the
clippers you come in you get a pure
point guard now
you know he's also used to being a guy
who
you know is is a primary scorer he's
going to clearly have to take a step
back as far as that goes but uh he is as
healthy as a guy who you know is his age
with his injury history can be i think
the fact he sat out all of last year can
only be a benefit to him you know he was
working out gave him a a chance to
really focus on his body and again for
six and a half million dollars i i think
it can be a really good value signing
for a clippers team that uh rightfully
expects to be contenders this year any
changes with the warriors
uh
the question is how many of their guys
can they keep kavon looney is the
priority there is significant interest
in gary payton ii uh around the league
i think otto porter jr there's going to
be interest in him around and the thing
is we're talking about guys who and
wiggins
well wiggins i think they it's fairly
likely they get an extension done he'll
certainly be back on the team but you
know with the guys the
uh their key uh complimentary players
the loonies the peytons the porters
every dollar they pay them you multiply
it by seven because they're so deep into
the luxury tax so
uh you know they they make a lot of
money uh those championship runs
generate a lot of revenue but the most
expensive payroll in basketball history
the price is only going to go up
the craziest thing that could happen in
free agency is what
the craziest thing that could happen in
free agency again i just is there a
rumor out there that you'd go wow
ah
i i there's not one just off the top of
my head right now but i do think that
the deandre ayton situation that we
discussed is by far
the biggest wild card and if you know
this is a guy who's the number one
overall pick i think if you line him up
next you know the last two decades worth
number one overall picks he's somewhere
in the middle uh he's he's a
huge piece of a team that went to the
finals followed up with having the best
record in the league
and it doesn't seem like the suns are a
real interest in having him back so
that's a
very unique situation and and he's he's
young coming off his rookie deal so if
he lands somewhere else i do think he's
a guy you know if it's a toronto for
example i think he's a guy that can
really push toronto into being a
legitimate threat into the eastern
conference what about zion any issues of
the pelicans is there a hold up uh and
what is the holdup for signing him to
the max
yeah i i think at this point it's it's
just about
what's the language in the contract you
know you go back for example with joel b
coming off the rookie extension that's
obviously the comp in terms of
the talent is unquestionable but
you're worried about how many games he's
missed the durability so what's you know
what kind of protection can the pelicans
get uh inserted into the contract if he
misses a lot of games and look you know
kristaps porzingis was another example
the mavs maxed him out with no entry
protection whatsoever so that's really
the only potential hold up zion's made
it clear that he's happy to be
in new orleans especially after the
pelicans made the moves they did last
season the pelicans clearly want to keep
them so you know we'll see what the
language in the contract ends up looking
like always great to talk to you tim
thanks for joining us
appreciate you having me dan that's tim
mcmahon espn nba reporter